I'm Abby Lee Miller and this is my pop
culture pyramid on the bottom of the
pyramid blast
Pedro Pascal
too scruffy for me
it's too scruffy next why didn't put her
last thank God almost last
Taylor Swift
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry please
don't send out the hate not about the
concert
however
let's talk about the feet
Taylor is pigeon toed she's turned in so
she's doing all this dance choreography
all this pop stuff
and it's so awkward
I love her singing but I liked it when
she was just kind of hunched over the
guitar playing it sitting in a chair the
whole pop star dancer singer actress
thing it ain't her it ain't her
and the next one on the bottom Brianna
let's talk Super Bowl performance I
loved it love the choreography but
they're elevated up and then nothing
happens they didn't flip off them and
down or the costumes the coats didn't
turn inside out and suddenly they were
another color there was so much more you
could have done
call me next time moving up to the
second row we have Haley Bieber
and Selena Gomez
now Haley Bieber come on you have to
give that girl credit she's living with
him that's a tough job right there okay
she has to deal with that every day and
Selena Gomez she has a little TV show
with Martin Short and Steve Martin and
she's great in it and I love that she's
really pushing the acting chops and
she's working with two great people that
I really admire for both film and
Broadway they're great and she's going
to get better at working with them top
of the pyramid
hello
me Abby Lee Miller if you're not going
to put yourself on top nobody else is
going to do it for you
foreign